with the media and big tech suppressing
every single story contradicting every
single story that might be
negative about joe biden president trump
has finally figured out a way
to get around them take a look at this
clip we had it made up and i think
you're like
first time i've ever done this right
first time go ahead wherever it is put
it up would there be
any place for fossil fuels including
coal and fracking
in a biden administration no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated and no more
subsidies for either one of those
i guarantee we're going to end fossil
fuel
no more no new fracking i'd gradually
move away from fracking
and i think it's critically important on
day one that we end
any fossil fuel leases on public lands
stopping fracking and stopping pipeline
structure
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to phase out fossil fuels
and we're going to phase out fossil
fuels
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking
and what we don't show is his more
current version oh yes we'll have
fracking
and the fake news they don't do anything
about it they don't even talk to him
about it
but right now he's got bigger problems
than fracking i think
right now he does have bigger problems
and that would be his son hunter biden's
laptop but you see that he uses tech
to get around the media which won't
cover the story
so and then it's being suppressed on big
tech so he plays the clip and then both
of them have to cover it i believe
that is inception but president trump
has more tricks
up his sleeve not just on the hunter
biden stuff
which he alluded to but also possibly
breaking up the biggest
tech giant in the world i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from zane who
says
every time joe biden says come on man he
assumes
someone's gender that's true of all the
issues that people are bringing up to
joe
nobody mentions that about how he keeps
assuming people's
gender he assumed corn pop's gender he
assumes
a lot of people's gender you know what
you can't assume though
that you can keep charging things to
your credit cards forever and ever and
ever and that'll be fine what you need
to do is consolidate all of that
lightstream offers
credit card consolidation loans from
5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
the application is 100
online you don't even have to leave your
house to apply and these days i think
you're not allowed to leave your house
so that works out very well
you can get a loan from five thousand to
one hundred thousand dollars
and there are absolutely no fees you can
even get your funds
as soon as the day you apply people love
livestream okay here's here's just what
one customer had to say
said i heard about lightstream while
listening to one of my favorite podcasts
i hope it was this one
and it prompted me to do more research
after shopping around for personal loan
that would help me get a lower interest
rate
there was no one easier to work with
plus lightstream had the best rate by
far
better yet no fees and i had my cash
within two business days
overall amazing experience highly
recommended right now
this is a great opportunity to solve
your credit card debt problem
consolidate that stop paying crazy
crazy rates and fees my listeners right
now can save even more with an
additional
interest rate discount the only way to
get this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
knowles k w l e s this is l i g h t s t
r e a m.com knowles subject credit
approval rate includes
0.50 autopay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit
terms and condition supply and offers
are subject to change without notice
visit livestream.com
knowles for more information
president trump had some choice words
there for the media because the media
won't
cover any of these stories in in this
case joe biden's saying for months and
months and months he's going to ban
fracking ban fossil fuels
then finally he changes his tune because
he wants to get votes in pennsylvania
which may well decide the election so
they won't cover it so what does he do
he knows that the media have to cover
his rallies because they're so wacky
they're so off the cuff
that some news might break and so at the
rally he uses multimedia
to play the clips which then the media
have to cover and not even big tech are
going to break up
at some of these events however
president trump has used
even choicer language for his friends in
the media
your state is doing great with a
pandemic
pandemic they're getting tired of the
pandemic aren't they
getting tired of the people you turn on
cnn that's all they cover
covet covert pen democracy
you know why they're trying to talk
everybody out of voting people aren't
buying it cnn you dumb
bastards they're not bargaining
that's all they talk about
you know that i of all the things
president trump does i probably like
99 of them the one thing that drives me
crazy is when he goes blue
i just don't like it i don't love the
vulgar language however i'm going to
take my personal
thoughts about this away for a second
and just look at it more as an objective
outside observer
there's a reason those people are
cheering
when president trump calls the media
stupid bastards there's a reason that
they cheer
and it's not just that they're a group
of hateful awful terrible people i bet
you every single trump voter in the
country
63 million people would cheer at that
and frankly i bet you another
30 million would cheer at that too who
didn't even vote for trump
because the mainstream media have lost
all of their credibility
and it's not just that they're hacks for
democrats for the past
six seven months they have been actively
trying to gin up fear gin up mayhem lock
people in their homes
all to win a presidential election that
is what the lockdown is about the
lockdown is about winning
a presidential election trump's analysis
there that they want to keep you all
terrified of going out and voting
is precisely so that they can have
widespread unsolicited mail-in voting
which we have never had in the history
of our country
and which we have already seen examples
of
vulnerability to fraud now their people
are going to tell you
there's no evidence that there has been
fraud in the past there's no evidence in
the past because we've never had this in
the past
this is completely brand new and it's
been brought on
because of these crazy lockdowns when
where the media
insists on the lockdowns or else we're
all going to die insists on the
lockdowns when it comes to church
insists on the lockdowns
when it comes to protests and systems a
lot of times when it comes to voting in
person
but does not want the lockdowns when it
comes to
mostly peaceful blm protests mostly
peaceful blm riots
mostly peaceful blm arson
okay i i get it president trump
it's it's easy to blame him for whipping
up this frenzy against the media
uh-uh buddy trump trump is the
consequence trump is the symptom
of a fury against the media which the
media have earned
through their thorough corruption and
you don't know the half of their
corruption
it gets so much worse
today because we now have
confirmation from the department of
justice and the fbi
that the hunter biden laptop and the
hunter biden
emails and the emails showing that he
was selling his dad's influence for
millions of dollars to ukraine into
china
and the emails suggestion that joe biden
was well
not only aware of this but he was
involved in this and
more evidence that joe biden was getting
a cut of this
of all this corruption selling out
america
the doj and the fbi confirmed this was
not russian disinformation
this what we've been told now for the
past two weeks more than two weeks
it's disinfo it's russian interference
no one should ever run this
we've got to suppress the story
twitter's not going to let people share
the link
new york post still locked out of
twitter a senior law enforcement
official is now
saying fbi doj concur with john ratcliff
who's the director of national
intelligence
hunter biden's laptop and the emails in
question weren't part of a russian
disinformation campaign
and the fbi now does have possession of
hunter biden's laptop
first of all the emails are obviously
real
how do i know they're real because not
only do they sound real not only
do they refer to real events
they include photographs of hunter biden
in very compromising positions so either
the
the photoshop people at the russian
disinformation camp or the
or the most qualified and skilled in the
world or these are photos and this is
real
material that comes from hunter biden
now that hasn't stopped the mainstream
media from pushing this disinformation
narrative just
just take a listen to the sort of people
who have
pushed the lie with with no evidence by
the way
that all this damaging info about the
bidens
joe and hunter is russian disinfo rachel
maddow msnbc nick schifrin pbs
yamiche alcindor pbs steve holzer cbs
news director
cbs news director who by the way
reprimanded in public
one of his reporters because his
reporter dared ask
joe biden about these issues of hunter's
emails
and joe's inappropriate relationship to
ukraine and china the reporter just
asked the question did what reporters do
cbs news director comes out there and
says how dare you you shouldn't do that
steve holzer politicians have pushed
this adam schiff
of course he probably cooked the whole
thing up himself chris murphy democratic
senator rep bill paschall rep david
sicilian
all democrats the blue check marks on
twitter who have pushed
this complete lie 100
we now have confirmation from three
intelligence agencies live
amy siskind uh who's a blue check on
twitter nera tandon from the center for
american progress
ben rhodes who was barack obama's
fabulous he was he was one of these
these complete blockheads behind the
iran deal and
and a lot of barack obama's foreign
policy
all of the pod save america guys they
just completely lied about this
evan mcmullen egg mcmuffin that that
jerk that that never trumper who ran for
president
in 2016. he was an xcia guy who was very
upset that trump was running against
his uh his intelligence community that
has obviously
taken way way way too much power bill
crystal remember bill crystal david frum
another
former republican i guess all these guys
pushed
this russian disinfo hoax without a
single shred of evidence
how about from big publications
washington post business insider
newsweek usa today cnn and many many
others i just don't have time to go
through all of them
this is what trump is up against
we've now we've heard from major media
figures
we've heard from major politicians we've
heard from major cultural figures
major republican figures even they're
fake republicans but they pretend to be
republicans
on tv and the biggest news outlets in
the world all arrayed against president
trump
pushing a complete fabrication
and you think you think when when
conservatives say that republicans don't
have
institutional power conservatives don't
have institutional power you say well
you got the white house you got the same
we don't have
nothing pal okay we've got some
positions in the government thankfully
we have the white house
and we're holding the senate but
compared to that
liberal establishment that i've just
described it's not very much it's not
very much and it is
astounding to me when i talk to my
democratic friends and relatives
and they just spout these hack talking
points that come from
all of these various people without
evidence i think oh you just the big
divide here
is not whether you are
this kind of a conservative or that kind
of a conservative or a liberal democrat
or new left or that
a big divide is do you believe the new
york times or not
do you believe what the establishment
are telling you or not do you still have
cr
faith in this establishment or
do you not and it so it doesn't cut
evenly across left and right
but there are there are some people who
still believe in it and that's why they
always get
misled but all those guys were lying
or at least were misled by people who
were lying
the computer is legitimate the emails
are legitimate
and even though joe biden told us that
he has nothing to do with job
with hunter biden's business deals we
now have a photo from that laptop
showing biden smiling with one of hunter
biden's
corrupt kazakh business partners
you know this scandal
that hunter biden is now involved in if
i had to draw
just one practical conclusion from that
it would be
you need to protect yourself online okay
this is my greatest segue ever in the
history of my show october is national
cyber security awareness month
and every day we put our information at
risk on the internet
you could miss certain identity threats
by just monitoring your credit
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like
for instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web
if you become a victim of identity theft
lifelock
can help you restore your identity
easier than what you can do
on your own it's not very smart to use
the same password for everything that's
one example
not very smart to go online not protect
your data not very smart to leave your
computer at repair shops for weeks at a
time
not very smart to do these things okay
you've got to protect yourself
online no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses
lifelock can see threats that you might
miss on your own join now and save up to
25 percent off your first year
go to lifelock.com knowles canadawes
that is a lifelock.com
knowles know w l e s for 25
off the guys that i trust head on over
there
now so it's legit forget about all those
photos with
with hunter biden with a cigarette
dangling from his teeth or
a pipe of some sort hanging from his
teeth those aren't the most interesting
ones
the other day when when people were
pushing those photos out
i i said that i don't think that's the
right
tack to take i don't think it's good to
make fun of him for being a drug addict
or anything like that
didn't occur to me though and it should
have it occurred to me shortly
thereafter but it should have occurred
to me in the moment then
the reason that those photos of hunter
biden with the cigarettes and the crack
pipes and all that came out
was not to make fun of hunter biden for
being a junkie
the reason those photos came out was to
show that this is obviously legitimate
material
because an oil painter didn't come up
with those pictures those were real
photos from the laptop
and those photos aren't the interesting
ones the photos that are interesting for
our purposes
are the ones showing joe biden smiling
with hunter's
corrupt kazakh business partners unless
you think by the way
lest you think that this is just some
accident i'll poor old joe
his son just suckered him into taking a
picture with these kazak guys
joe biden is a very shrewd politician
he's not a very intelligent man he's not
a very honest man he's not a very
accomplished man
in terms of what he's actually
accomplished while in office he's had
the accomplishment of being in office
for a long time
but he is a shrewd politician that's how
he stayed in office so long
he knew that his presence in those
photos
would be of value to those kazak guys he
was offering
that value okay you don't pull the wool
over joe biden's eyes when it comes to
pure politics okay you might on a host
of other issues but the guy's a slick
politician and nobody should pity him
in the realm of politics so this photo
was first published
last year at an anti-corruption website
called the kazakhstani initiative on
asset recovery and this didn't get a lot
of play when it was published there but
now
we've got the photo too reports to show
hunter biden and joe biden together with
kazakhstan's former prime minister karim
massimov at the far right and at the far
left kanez
rakhishev who is a junior partner of
timur
kulebayev stay with me and rakhishev
is a prominent investor and entrepreneur
regarded as one of the most influential
businessmen in kazakhstan rakhishev is
among the 50 most influential people
in kazakhstan obviously connections to
all these oligarchs
hunter biden doing business with them
why is he some
expert on kazakhstan
business affairs no i don't think so he
was peddling his father's influence
and as the photo shows
joe biden was helping him out to do it
raises a lot of questions one of the
messages from hunter biden's computer
says that he kicks back half of his
salary to pops who's pops is it corn pop
or is it papa biden what did he mean by
that i don't know i guess we're guess
we're gonna have to find out
by the way by the way you know the post
broke this story the new york post
the oldest continually published daily
newspaper in the country founded
by alexander hamilton
the post is still not allowed back on
twitter
dave now jack dorsey came out he
realized that the federal government is
about to smack him really hard
so he allowed people to start posting
the link a little bit more
but the post is still not on twitter
the in-kind contribution that twitter is
making to the biden campaign
by continuing to suppress this
information
by suppressing the outlet that is
breaking this information
is impossible to calculate what is it
worth
millions certainly it's worth millions
might be worth 10 million or 20 million
it's worth a lot of money
which sounds like an fec violation to me
sounds like
sounds like the federal election
commission should look into twitter's
practices
because there are many ways in which big
tech is breaking the law
we'll get to that in a second with
google but but twitter is
breaking the law not just in a matter of
antitrust i don't think they're going to
go after twitter for antitrust
not breaking the law and maybe maybe
they're breaking the law when it comes
to section 230 of the communications
decency act
but they are certainly violating
campaign finance law right now
and it would be it would be a shame if
the federal government let that go
without addressing it however the doj
has
a bigger fish to fry right now when it
comes to big tech because the doj this
is probably
the biggest news story when it comes to
business or technology
maybe of my lifetime certainly the last
20 years
the doj is now moving to break up
google as a monopoly they are suing
google
they've filed a 57-page complaint that
has been filed in the u.s district court
in d.c
accusing google of locking out
competition and the way that they're
they're going after this suit
is pretty interesting because it's not
the way a lot of people expected them to
go after the suit
it's it's in a more specific way that
actually will have
broader implications and
you know one of the issues we'll get to
specifically what that is in a second
one of the issues with big tech is that
they can see you
everywhere they can keep an eye on you
everywhere
and that's a very bad thing when you are
being spied on but it's a very good
thing when you can keep an eye
on your home your family your pets your
belongings and get some peace of mind
you can do that with a ring there's a
reason there are there are a thousand
reasons why protecting your home
should matter to you ring has security
products for every corner of your home
inside and out best of all
you can see it all in one simple app
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are whether
you're in your home whether you're at
the office whether you're on a beach
somewhere
you know i give out the the ring starter
kit to my friends as a housewarming gift
well guess what i'm getting a house in
nashville now
i'm going to get a house and i cannot
wait to protect
my house i'm so excited to be the
recipient of the gift
that i usually give to my friends when
we get on over to that house i will give
you an update
because if somebody stops by something's
going on ring will let you know they'll
let you know if it's a delivery man
they'll let you know if it's a marauder
they will let you know if it's your
mother-in-law
and really who's to say which one of
those is
is worse which is better it's very very
hard to say get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid
ring dot com slash knowles can wles
comes with
rings video doorbell 3 and chime pro the
absolute perfect way to start your ring
experience
plus two day free shipping go to ring
dot com slash knowles canada w l e s
that is ring
dot com slash knowles k w l e
s the way that the doj
is looking to break up google is
interesting we sort of expected them to
go after
i don't know youtube let's say youtube
right youtube really is the
video player for the whole internet and
they suppress
information and they they churn out
voices that they don't like
and there's no way to compete against
them and everyone says well what about
i don't know vimeo what about whatever
right yeah even vimeo which has been
around forever
no competition whatsoever against
youtube you can't you can't just go out
and make your own youtube right
but that's not how they're going after
them they're going after
search google has a zillion products
right they have
gmail they have google
voice they've got youtube they've got
google glasses they've got all sorts of
stuff right
search is their core competency search
is where all of google's power
comes from and what the doj is saying is
that their search
is effectively a monopoly and you know
this
we see this with conservative issues all
the time
google suppresses conservative results
they boost up
left-wing results and by doing that
they manipulate the flow of information
they control something like 80 of the
information flow around the internet
and so and by the way if you are on the
first page of google
you're there you exist you're on the
internet if you're on page two you might
as well not exist
it's it's that stark and they are
controlling that in a way
that is according to the doj
monopolistic
okay these are the stakes that we've got
right now
you've got three companies but really
it's google google's the big dog
facebook and twitter much less so you've
got these companies controlling the flow
of information around the internet
controlling our public square the public
square is essential in a free government
in self-government where we have to
persuade our fellow citizens they are
controlling our speech and they have no
accountability whatsoever they acquired
that ability
through fraud by telling people
that they were entering into some one
product and then giving them a different
product
telling people that they were entering
into being able to share their
information around
and then pull the wool pull the rug out
from under them
start suppressing political views that
they don't like through the fraud
of enjoying protection from section 230
and saying we're going to be a neutral
tech platform and then actually sorry
we're going to act as a publisher but
we're still going to get that subsidy
because of the liability protection
they've done
all of that and even beyond all those
legal issues you just zoom in from a
political issue
we can't abide that we can't abide very
very
bad people with very very
anti-american views controlling the
american public sphere
there's there's no argument there's no
conservative argument for that there's
no libertarian argument for that there's
no
liberal argument it you cannot have that
in free government and those are the
stakes
these issues you know people talk about
trump's twitter or whatever
we should be talking about twitter
twitter not trump's twitter twitter is
the issue
who cares what trump is tweeting
these are the stakes there is no excuse
for any non-leftist
not to vote for donald trump in this
election i don't care you don't like the
way he talks i don't care
you you don't like that he uses vulgar
language about the press i don't i
actually don't like that either
but get your priorities in order man
this
is these are the stakes this is by far
the most conservative president of my
lifetime
but he's kind of the lone voice against
this entire establishment
that threatens to snuff out
self-government itself
i don't think that's an overstatement
doj doesn't think that's an
overstatement
there is no issue that could possibly
justify
a non-leftist voting for joe biden
or egg mcmuffin or whatever the
libertarian candidate is or whatever
you i understand that it doesn't feel
morally pure all the time to go in and
actually
vote and actually do anything it
requires courage and it requires you to
be able to take a risk
we have to do that some people are not
willing to do that former chairman of
the republican national committee
michael steele an absolute joke
michael steele came out and endorsed
joe biden imagine that night
tension's high a nation torn apart
a plot here in baltimore city to
assassinate a newly elected president
on his way to inauguration and to plunge
the country
into chaos abraham lincoln disembarked
at this train station and under pre-dawn
skies
made his way unscathed and under
greatness
in the days ahead we may face a crisis
of similar proportion
an outlaw president clinging to power
and defying the will of the people
for four years many have said there will
come a moment
well this is the moment because this
ballot
is like none ever cast now i'm a
lifelong republican
and i'm still a republican but this
ballot is how we restore the soul of our
nation
electing a good man joe biden and a
trailblazer kamala harris
and ensure an orderly transfer of power
or
plunge our country into chaos america
or trump i choose america
the lincoln project is responsible for
the content of this advertising
joe biden is not a good man and kamala
harris is not a trailblazer how is joe
biden a good man
well trump lies joe biden has told many
many more lies than donald trump and
much more importantly than that
joe biden has told much more
consequential lies
than donald trump donald trump lies
meaning
exaggerates about his crowd sizes and
maybe he gets
a few statistics or facts wrong every
now and again which by the way isn't a
lie if you do it unintentionally
joe biden had to drop out of the 1988
presidential race because he lied very
intentionally
joe biden has lied about his views on
fracking for just to use the one example
at the top of the show
joe biden lied about the the a man
involved in
a horrible family tragedy with joe biden
where his where his wife was killed in a
car accident
the man who was involved in that car
accident felt terrible for his whole
life but you know they sort of
made made peace and then the minute that
guy died joe biden lied about him and
said he was a drunk driver
horribly damaging to this guy's family
joe biden has lied about his views on
just about every single issue
joe biden lies about stories in the past
all the time
you mean a good man and now it looks
like he might be a crook
that's what the evidence seems to
suggest he's and how is kamala harris a
trailblazer
really i suspect what michael steele is
alluding to is the way that everyone
uses this phrase trailblazer now
which is to refer to people's skin color
or sex but
she's not a trailblazer on race we've
already had a black president she's not
a trailblazer on sex because we've
already had a female vice presidential
candidate
sarah palin and geraldine ferraro for
that matter so she's not a trailblazer
in any way she's a hack politician who
like joe biden doesn't have any
principles and goes whichever way the
wind blows
you're gonna pick that over trump why
because my country matt the soul of our
country what's soul of our country joe
biden is suing nuns
joe biden is calling for abortion up
until the moment of birth at taxpayer
expense
soul of our country that's disgusting
that's despicable
soul of our country but but michael
steele is just using words
he doesn't mean any of these things
michael steele was always a squish
don't forget that michael steele was
always a squish back in
in 2009 michael steele
threw rush limbaugh under the bus a much
more important and significant
conservative
than michael steele because
it actually revealed the role of the
michael steeles of the world
and the other squishy republicans in the
kind of framework of liberalism
in 2009 barack obama is inaugurated and
uh rush limbaugh has asked can you give
us four paragraphs i think was in the
washington post can you give us four
paragraphs on what you hope to see from
this president
and he said i don't need four paragraphs
i need four words
i hope he fails makes perfect sense
barack obama said he wanted to
fundamentally transform america i hope
he fails
barack obama wanted to socialize our
health care i hope he fails of course
makes perfect sense
and he was castigated for this including
by michael steele who said that russia's
commentary was
ugly or not not even just in that
specific case but generally was ugly
you know michael steele he did preside
or he was the chairman of the rnc during
the 2010 midterms which were very good
for the gop
because of the tea party the tea party
was what led that election but
i don't think that was michael steele's
leadership i think that was obamacare i
think
i don't think anybody said i'm going out
to vote because michael steele did a
good job
no they said i'm going out to vote
because of obamacare so does he get a
little credit for that maybe but
you know you're talking about a once in
a hundred years issue
certainly once in a generation issue the
reason that michael steele didn't like
rush limbaugh the reason that michael
steele is endorsing joe biden the reason
that michael steele
essentially said that he hoped barack
obama would succeed
by disagreeing with rush who said i hope
he fails is that michael steele's job
the role of squishy republicans in the
liberal framework
is to be losers that's their job and the
liberals actually need them
if the liberals didn't have republicans
rolling over and pretending to put up a
fight but then rolling over
they would have a crisis of legitimacy
the regime wouldn't seem
legitimate because there would be an
opposition that was underground
but as long as you have a fake
opposition that is a little above ground
and they you know they take a couple
swings
they go into the ring and they maybe
throw a punch or two but then they get
clocked in the head and they take a fall
like they're supposed to
unless you have that the regime is not
legitimate
you see plenty of loser republicans like
this mitt romney is kind of the classic
example of this
he goes out he puts up a little bit of a
fight and then ultimately he wants
liberalism to succeed
and to advance john mccain same thing in
his political career he wanted
liberalism to advance and he'd put up a
little fight as a republican
but does anybody really think if john
mccain were still alive today they would
be endorsing trump in this election
uh something tells me i don't think so
there have been a lot of republicans
like that for way
way way too long okay
squishes and outright political
subversives
have dominated the republican party for
too long and then you got trump
and trump's got some problems i guess
but you know what i don't care
i don't care because he's actually
putting up the fight
and i think that's why they're pushing
back on him so hard i think that's why
right now you're seeing such kind of
chaos in the country social chaos that
the left is instigating
and by the way when there is social
chaos it's a good time to have gold
here's
something new i really i really like
these guys this is a pretty incredible
product
you know how the price of gold has been
skyrocketing well now there is a way to
buy gold through a company called
acre you might say michael i don't have
any money to buy gold well i think you
do
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30
a month you pay each month once your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they discreetly ship acre gold to your
house this is physical gold which is
very important to have especially when
times are turbulent
acre lets you invest in physical gold
without it coming out of pocket all at
once
very helpful for those of us who can't
just be dropping money on gold bars
every single day
acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month ships once you reach
the price threshold with acre taking
physical delivery of your gold
means it is safe and sound and in your
hands
actually for a number of years now i
have enjoyed investing
in precious metals in physical precious
metals
it's just something very conservative
about that you know because you got it
you can actually have it in your hand
visit
getacregold.com knowlescanawles
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
they are giving away a bar
of gold pretty good qualify for the
giveaway
by tweeting or posting why you should be
the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
a-c-r-e
that is get acre gold
e g o g-e-t-a-c-r-e-g-o-l d dot com
slash knowledge wlas
thank you aker gold for supporting our
show
with everything going on in 2020 by the
way you know there's a lot of drama with
the debates well get ready
because the final debate is tomorrow you
can join us at 8 45 pm eastern 5 45
pacific for an all-new episode of daily
wire backstage to watch the debate with
us
you can join daily wire now as an
insider or all access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all the debate coverage live on our
apple tv
or roku apps do it head on over
dailywire.com you can watch it you can
watch it on youtube you can watch it on
facebook and more importantly you get 20
off your daily wire membership with code
debate when you sign up today
stick around we'll be right back with a
lot more
so michael steele former rnc chairman is
a loser i'm not saying that as a petty
insult i'm saying that is what he's
actively doing he is saying i the former
rnc chairman i'm going to
endorse joe biden the democrat because i
want our party to lose
but not everybody is a loser like that
some people
want to be winners my favorite recent
endorsement for president trump
comes from none other than fiddy fiddy
sen
fitty said i mentioned this very briefly
at the end of the show yesterday but i
really want to
just get into the full endorsement here
he tweets out
all caps what the f f
star star star vote for trump
i'm out f new york the knicks never win
anyway i don't care trump doesn't like
black people
62 percent are you out of your effing
mind
is the 62 he is alluding to here
is the joe biden tax proposal which
would tax the rapper
at 62 percent wow that is a lot
of money isn't it and uh you know
the reason it would tax people that high
is because you have
state taxes as well and local taxes as
well
and so blue states which levy very high
state and local taxes all of a sudden
you add that to the federal tax which
biden is going to increase
and you you end up working 62 percent of
the year
for the government what does
freedom mean if 62
of your year you are a surf
to the government i i am not of the
opinion that taxes are illegitimate by
definition i'm not of the opinion that
all taxation is theft i mean it's kind
of that's a funny line that
conservatives and really more
libertarians say sometimes but i'm not
of that opinion however when you get to
62
now you're in a really dangerous
territory and fitty fitty cent realizes
that
and so he's coming out and saying i
don't care if trump doesn't like black
people
i think fiddy is joking here by the way
because
does anyone in their right mind believe
donald trump doesn't like black people
donald trump was winning awards with
rosa parks decades ago the only time
anyone ever accused
trump of racism is when he ran for
office as a republican if he had
run as a democrat which he could have no
one would accuse him of that sort of
thing
contrary to the popular media
representation trump has
denounced white supremacy about 700
zillion times in his career
so i don't but i think he's i think he's
joking i think what fiddy is doing here
is joking about because
if if he really felt that trump were you
know a white supremacist
or something somebody tells me even the
62 he wouldn't vote for him
what he's saying is yeah okay we hear
all this blah blah blah about
trump hates black people yeah i don't
care man what is that what does that
mean in real life
if trump seriously hated black people
how has that manifested has it
manifested by him
creating policies that have given great
opportunity to black people
has his white supremacy manifested by
trump affecting the lowest black
unemployment rate in history of the
country
has that manifested by president trump
making an explicit request
for the black vote because he said that
democrats have been
screwing over black people for hundreds
of years and what have you got to lose
is it is it because trump has black
friends
you know i know that left for some
reason they always say oh how dare you
mention that you have black friends
that's not proof that you're not racist
i think it is pretty sure it is
they actually the left always wants to
cut that off and kind of mock the idea
that because you have black friends
you're not a racist
uh as as being somehow illegitimate but
i think they want to cut that off
because
it is simply the case that if you have
black friends you're not a racist
it's just the way it is you don't if you
really judge people
uh you know as inferior and superior on
the
on the basis of race then you're you're
not going to associate on an equal
playing field with people that you think
are
by definition inferior trump has a lot
of black friends
so kanye west would be an example of
this another rapper who's gone for trump
there seems to be an
interesting grouping of rappers here who
are going for donald trump which should
be no surprise to anyone who's been
paying attention
because donald trump has appeared in
many many many rap songs over the years
as someone to emulate just that idea of
donald trump breaking the stodgy old
republican mold
the loser republican mold another reason
that he's been able to transform the
party and and threaten the liberal
regime because he's not willing to just
play the court jester in the kingdom of
liberalism not all celebrities though
are like fiddy not all celebrities
like president trump john leguizamo
who's actually quite a good actor but a
very annoying political commentator john
leguizamo went on the bill maher show
and he said that it
it is absolutely unacceptable for
hispanics to vote for trump
there was an article i saw in the paper
this week that talked about how
and i thought this was sort of trading
on stereotypes it said that the
trump is doing rather well with young
latino men
because of the makismo factor
and well i see you're shaking your head
is that is it bad
people for republicans are like roaches
for rape
let's just get real so
[Applause]
i i just feel like there's a level of
of self-hate or just lack of care for
the rest of your latin brothers and
sisters who are
in cages who are are being demonized by
this president i mean hate crimes
against latin people
way up and how can you not i mean
23 people were shot in el paso for just
being latin
and and and you and you don't care so
you're going to go for this
braggadocio president i just feel like
it's
welcoming and selfish so not much of an
argument there you see john leguizamo
trying to
make several arguments but he can't
complete the thought because none of
them cohere so
he'll make one he'll say you're going to
vote and people in cages
what do you mean latin people in cages
oh he's referring to those photos that
were going around when president trump
was enforcing our border
and it showed some people i don't know
kind of in cages or
behind at least behind metal and
what john leguizamo doesn't know is
those photos came from 2014 and those
photos
were from the obama administration
because the guy who put the
the illegal aliens in cages was barack
obama and the policy that
required this sort of behavior came from
the clinton administration
came all the way back from the 90s so
not trump's fault then he blames him
because there were shootings in
el paso trump is now responsible for el
paso
doesn't make a lot of sense what about
beta or work wasn't he isn't bait or
work wasn't he the representative from
el paso
no it doesn't blame him it just blames
trump there's no argument here
and what he's what he's playing into is
this oppression narrative
which was contrived in the 1970s and 80s
largely by the ford foundation actually
but by a lot of left-wing activists who
saw
the effectiveness of the black civil
rights and black power movement in the
1960s and 70s
and tried to replicate it for other
groups but the thing about this is mike
gonzalez actually
puts this very well in his recent book
and it's called the plot to change
america
the the kind of grievance politics only
works for black people
if it works at all it only works for
black people and specifically the
descendants of slaves
because only black people came to the
united states
on slave ships in chains against their
will all the other groups
came to the united states voluntarily
somebody's great granddaddy somebody's
ancestors down the line
chose to come to america they came here
for a purpose because it was better to
come here than to stay where they were
and so it's completely incoherent for
these you know extraordinarily
privileged great
great grandchildren like john leguizamo
a millionaire actor hollywood celebrity
to come out and say we're all so
oppressed no you're not
not only are you not oppressed now but
your ancestors weren't oppressed they
chose
to come here voluntarily but they try to
do this with every single group they're
doing it now with
middle east north africa people from the
middle east have always been classified
as white in the united states
but in the past decade or so especially
during the obama administration
they tried to reclassify them as middle
east north africa linda sarsour
was behind this linda sarsour was one of
the voices behind this
and she's a radical left-wing activist
she started wearing a hijab
she was asked once why why do you wear
the hijab she said if i don't wear the
hijab
then i'm just another boring white lady
in new york
it shows you the the reality of white
privilege so-called
if there were such a thing as white
privilege then people wouldn't
be trying to disassociate
with white people and identify with a
new group called middle east north
africa
the actual privilege is to be part of an
aggrieved victimized minority
there is no privilege for being i mean
you just see this in affirmative action
right you see this
in hiring practices and college
acceptance practices
so john like was i've no one's ever
accused john leguizamo of being the most
sophisticated political philosopher in
the world
but his argument here with the with the
latinos has all of those premises behind
it and then it plays on a concept that
goes all the way back to karl marx and
it was really expanded
by what you call neo-marxists or
cultural marxists under
antonio gramsci for instance or the new
left herber marcus a lot of these
a lot of these people you saw throughout
the 20th century who were explicit
marxists working in the cultural sphere
they would describe false consciousness
the feminists
of the 1970s made this the uh
into the mainstream the the idea of a
false consciousness being
it comes it comes from these
consciousness-raising groups
that radical women would have around new
york they and women would go there and
say gosh i never knew i was oppressed
before i went to the meeting i thought i
had a nice happy life but after i left
the meeting my consciousness was raised
the way the phrase exists today is
called raising awareness but then it was
called raising consciousness
my consciousness was raised and now i
realize how aggrieved and victimized and
oppressed i am and that's what john
leguizamo is saying these people
they're self-hating hispanics they hate
themselves it's like a roach voting for
raid
it's they don't get it they think
they're happy and they think they love
america and they think they have a good
life
and they think their ancestors came here
for a reason but they're wrong it's
actually all terrible it's
be miserable be miserable like me that's
what he's telling them
and the most ridiculous of all came from
elizabeth warren
who said that trump is not just
threatening one specific group in her
case i suppose the cherokee
but that president trump is threatening
all life on earth
we are reaching a moment on our planet
in which the crisis that is upon us
may no longer be one that we will be
able to successfully fight back against
the climate crisis is here and no
it is not the science around this is not
controversial
the science is clear in fact you know
what scares me to death
is every time we get more data and
re-analyze the data what we discover is
the problems even worse than we thought
we have even less time than we thought
and so what has donald trump done for
four years
he not only hasn't made things better he
has actively
made them worse donald trump threatens
the existence of human life of
all life on this planet can somebody get
senator warren a fainting couch please
she is becoming
positively hysterical
i love this idea that the democrats
always do this because they're always
fear-mongering they're doing it on the
virus as president trump said to the
press right at the very top of the show
today
and they're doing it on the environment
they're doing it they've been doing it
for decades and decades they used to do
it on population the population bomb
were all going to be starving by the
1980s what happened
the world population doubled and people
have never been richer fatter
they they do it where they did it with
global cooling in the 1970s and we're
all heading for an ice age and then now
they're doing with global warming and
who knows they're going to do it with
global
moderation pretty so who knows she goes
listen listen we we told you that
the world was going to end in 12 years
well now it's actually ah it's gonna be
sooner even
is it sooner ten years is that well is
that enough to get you all
terrified i've had nine years how about
it's gonna end in 95 minutes if you
don't vote for us right now please
please vote for us help us the world is
gonna end
i don't think so aoc told what is it two
years ago she told us it was going to
end in 12 years keep
track of that clock by the way because
now we're down to 10 or even less than
10.
actually a couple years ago prince
charles one of the kookier members of
the british royal family told us the
world was going to end in 18 months
which by my by my clock means that the
world has ended
it's over we've it's ended and i guess
are we in heaven now are we in hell
uh-oh well looking around the political
scene
doesn't feel like heaven obviously these
things are preposterous the world
is not i mean no one knows the time or
the hour but at least the sun monster is
probably not going to end the world
within
elizabeth warren's timetable they're
ginning up this
hysteria on the racial issue like john
leguizamo and then on the
global planetary issue like elizabeth
warren
because they're losing power and because
for the first time in my lifetime
republicans are not willing to just be
losers and play their assigned role
whether that's in the media you know
sometimes there's there's the one
conservative place but they're not
really conservative they actually roll
over
or in the elected government you know
there are a few conservative policies
but they're not really conservative they
just roll over they're like michael
steele
or in wherever
for the first time you got a guy pushing
back against these things
on on the hunter biden stuff on the doj
on the fbi
i will tell you this is we're talking
about firsts in our lifetime
this is by far the most impressive
october surprise of my lifetime usually
before elections in october
you will have some big campaign reveal
in 2016 the october surprise that
democrats had
was they had a video of donald trump
cracking jokes with billy bush
during access hollywood cracking jokes
about oh yeah i
this woman will let me do whatever i
want that sort of thing locker room talk
as it was called
in 2020 we now have evidence
that the biden family is crooked and
also that they were looking at kitty
porn on hunter's laptop
we didn't even touch on that today i
guess we'll have to get to that tomorrow
we still have like what two or three
weeks until the election
the this is that famous chinese curse
may you live in interesting times we're
already living through one chinese curse
now we've got another one too the one
thing i can i'm not going to predict the
future the one
thing i can promise you though october
is not over and many surprises are yet
to come i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. hey everybody it's andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton